hello everyone and welcome to today's
live presentation polypharmacy a
healthcare dilemma with a genomic
medicine solution presented by Ronald
Feld as jr. PhD professor in chief
clinical chemistry in toxicology
Department of pathology and Laboratory
Medicine University of Louisville School
of Medicine I am Christina mahalik of
lab routes and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by laberd's Leopards is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know if you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Valdes I will now turn the presentation
over to him dr. bell des the floor is
yours
thank you very much Christina for the
introduction and good day to all of you
in the audience I'm very pleased to be
here today and fortunate to have the
opportunity to pay attention to some of
the subjects that I'm going to be
discussing and I'm I'm always very
excited about talking about how the
Clinical Laboratory can play a role and
assist in the concept of polypharmacy
and pharmacotherapy and i bet that many
of you if not yourselves or your
relatives or loved ones are in a
situation where they're taking many
medicines simultaneously on a daily
basis and that's considered to be
polypharmacy if it's more than three or
four medicines a day and you know it's
it's an issue that I think is a growing
concern and I believe that the clinical
laboratory can have a strong impact on
how this might be managed going forward
so first of all let me just point out
that I have no specific conflicts of
interest related to this particular
presentation I'm employed by the
University of Louisville funded by the
NIH for much of my work etc okay so what
will we be discussing today in the next
40 minutes or so there are four topics
that really would like to go over one of
them is precision versus personalized
medicine those are two words and I'm
going to try to describe for you because
I know that sometimes they can be
confusing the other issue is what is
polypharmacy and how much of a problem
is it really Rus to tackle the third one
has to do with pharmacogenomics as a
potential solution for this problem and
then some aspects about how to implement
programs that might actually help to
relieve the problem using clinical
laboratory science so let's get started
first by looking at what we consider to
give if you look at the future of
Medicine one of the most disruptive
transformations that are taking place
really has less to do with who's going
to pay for medical care and how they're
distributed I believe that it
fundamentally has to do with the
transition from intuitive medicine to a
precision medicine practice and this is
written about very nicely in a text book
that I'm going to show you in just a
second but the two words that typically
come up in the discussion and in the
literature are precision medicine and
personalized medicine so the real
question is what do they mean well
describe those in a little bit more
detail precision medicine really deals
with the accuracy and precision of a
diet
that is how much do we know about the
disease-causing process what is the
mechanism of the disease that links
precision medicine to its definition
personalized medicine on the other hand
really deals with a therapeutic approach
tailored to a specific individual not to
a group of individuals now let me take
you to the next slide so I can show you
and give you a perspective of what I
think this really means this is a taken
from a text book that was put together
by doctor Kristensen at Harvard and he
does explain a lot of other things that
I would recommend you you try to assess
it's the textbook published in 2009 very
relevant now and what this shows is a
figure of a scattergram current map of
common medical conditions and when you
look at these conditions they're on two
axes in that the x axis which is the
horizontal axis and on that axis you
have basically the extent of
understanding the mechanism causing a
disease and it goes from the left hand
side intuitive to the right hand size
precise the more you are to the right
the more precise you know what causes
the disease on the other hand the other
axis the x @dy axis rather the vertical
axis again goes from intuitive to
precise going up and it's deals with the
extent of treatment efficacy that is
basically how well does a treatment work
and these different medical conditions
can be placed in various locations and
quadrants along these axes and if you
look carefully here you're going to find
that there are four areas that are
important for example take appendicitis
on the left hand side there is very
little known about what causes the
condition but it's very treatable you
treat it you remove the appendix and the
treatment is very efficacious depression
on the other hand on the bottom there is
both intuitive from a mechanism
perspective we don't know what causes it
then we certainly are very ineffective
at treating it and then on the right
hand side on the bottom you have multi
drug-resistant tuberculosis and
basically we know what causes that we
know the bugs but we can't treat it and
that's why it's multi throughout the
resistance and then on the top right
hand side is where things
very exciting and one example is strep
throat okay well we know basically what
causes it and we know that the treatment
is very effective and this is what leads
to rules based practices and
standardization in medicine so when you
look carefully where you really want to
be is way up there on the right hand
side because if you look at the x-axis
that could represent precision medicine
and on the y-axis that could represent
basically personalized medicine and they
both interplay with each other and they
basically both complement each other and
reinforce each other so that's based on
that definition there I think we need to
start looking at the bigger picture and
that is on this slide here where you
look at personalized medicine what does
it mean well you know this diagram is a
circular diagram which basically starts
at the bottom with traditional medicine
it defines the pathologic States and the
clinical observations and on either side
on one side on the right hand side
you've got personal genomics which
really deals with connecting the
phenotype to the phenotype and providing
insight into the disease ie the
precision medicine part of this whole
thing the personal genomics the
left-hand side you've got therapies that
related to drug pharmacogenomics and
that's where you connect genotype the
patient's specific treatments so when
you look at this whole picture you start
getting our understanding as to how
precision medicine and personalized
medicine might play a role and basically
interlocking and reinforcing each other
so let's get on with what we mean by
polypharmacy I want you to look at the
right hand side this is a figure taken
from the New York or some years ago and
there's a lady standing in front of her
doctor and she says I think that those
sheets adjusting I'm not nearly as happy
as the people in the ads and this is a
very common problem medicines don't
always work and I'm going to be
describing them so polypharmacy let's
talk about what is the problem what
causes the problem and what can
laboratory medicine possibly provide as
solutions well from polypharmacy is a
national
that's the first thing we need to
recognize and it's not recognized as a
disease or condition but perhaps it
ought to be because of the great
implication for example there over this
is the letter literature taken from 2011
12 and 13 there over 4.2 billion
prescriptions written in the u.s. in
2011 hey that's an average of about 13
prescriptions for average American this
is back in 2011 it's probably larger now
4.1 prescriptions taken by by American
adults and over 12 prescriptions are
filled by the average American each year
so when you look at the right-hand side
you'll see that 46 percent of American
adults take prescriptions as of at least
2012 numbers probably higher now 34
percent of Americans take at least one
in the eleven percent take at least
three or more prescription medications
and what that means is that 6.5 percent
of American adults are taking four or
more medicines that are prescribed if
you look at the data it's published in
JAMA as early as 2002 this was
recognized for years this is data
showing that both men and women as they
progress in age a number of medications
that they're using increases for example
the dark bar under men okay on average
says that 50% of men basically total
that we're taking at least one medicine
and approximately 7% on average we're
taking greater than five medicines but
as you increase in age of through 65
almost seventy one percent or eighty one
percent of men and women were taking at
least one medicine and somewhere in the
vicinity of 20 to 25 were taken at least
I prescribed medications if you look at
some additional data coming from our
laboratory this is a study that we did
on 30,000 individuals basically from a
retired population and on the x-axis you
see the number of medications that were
being taken per patient and on the
y-axis basically the number of patients
that were taking that many medicines and
you can see that
92% of the patients or taking three or
more medications I'm gonna and this is
real data okay taken from an organized
study that we did I'm gonna show you
this a little bit later and what the
impact this really is from the
standpoint of polypharmacy and
cost-effectiveness I'll be referring
this back in the well so one of the cost
consequences well polypharmacy is very
costly in 2001 our country spent over
200 billion dollars on prescription
medications in 2008 it was 234 roughly
and in 2012 just five years ago it was
over three hundred and twenty six
billion dollars of medicines the other
thing is that it has consequences
there's you know what relative to
hospital admissions if you look at the
number sixteen percent of hospital
admissions nowadays are related to
adverse drug reactions you know
medicines and it's been it's been
basically determined that they're over
forty main forty to seventy different
potential reactions to an average
prescription drug and you can listen to
the TV advertising and they try to fit
in you know the most five or six
relevant ones it is the leading cause of
death one of the leading cause of death
in the country and I'll show you some
data on that and frankly it's been
indicated that there are more deaths to
adverse drug reactions and from actually
overdosing on administered drugs from
illegal drugs so there's a huge huge
importance and serious consequences if
you look at the adverse drug reactions
and the leading cause of death you know
it's probably considered to be the
fourth leading cause of death with
overwhelm over 100,000 individuals and
the thing that's interesting is that 60%
of medicines in the top 20 list that
causing the ADRs the adverse drug
reactions are linked to genetic
variations and if you look closely at
what the FDA box warnings are on many of
these medicines that there are over 165
drugs that have FDA box warnings related
to genetics so it gives you a good clue
that possibly looking at genetic
information might be helpful
okay so when you look at the healthcare
conundrum it is a conundrum polypharmacy
is growing at a very rapid rate 30 to 40
percent of elderly patients take at
least five medications this leads to
drug drug interactions we'll be
describing those in a little bit the
adverse drug reactions are a leading
cause of death in the u.s. most of this
leads to prescribing Cascades or the
first medicine requires multiple
subsequent medications not only for side
effects but because it may not be
working by chronic dependence is also
attributed polypharmacy
and you know the numbers suggest that
there are well over two million
hospitalizations annually in the adverse
drug reactions and I've already
indicated that over a hundred thousand
or fatalities so we understand that
polypharmacy is both a health care and
an economic burden
so then what causes the problem let's
focus on that for a couple of minutes
what situations can lead to the use of
so many medication well there are
several reasons that come to mind and
I'm going to review just a few of them
with you the first one is that drug
function is complex in many situations
on the left hand side you have an
example of what's called a pro drug
where the drug is ingested and then it
requires active metabolism before the
actual drug becomes active that liver
takes place typically in the liver so
the drug is not active until it's
metabolized so right away there's a
component where the body has to act on
the drug on the right hand side you've
got active drugs that are taken and then
those drugs have to be eliminated
appropriately through the kidney or the
bowels or other mechanisms so you've got
two different situations here that
depend on the individual that's one
reason drugs are complex
secondly many medicines do not work for
their intended purpose this was an
article published in Nature two to three
years ago 2015 indicating and the title
of the article was an N of 1 in terms of
studies and its title
in precision medicine and it basically
indicates that for every person that
they do help the ones in blue hey the
ten highest grossing drugs in the United
States fail to improve the conditions of
between three and twenty four people in
red and the way the state is obtained is
through studies where how many
individuals does it take to provide a
medicine where they take it to then see
the given effect that you expect and you
can see that it's very few okay this is
for standard medications that are top
ten grossing medicines in the country
medicine for schizophrenia for arthritis
for depression heartburn high
cholesterol asthma psoriasis so this is
a potential dilemma and one of the
questions you begin to ask is why is it
that they just don't work that well for
their intended purpose and one operation
that you can look at right here is the
patient response variability this takes
us into this realm of genetics or you've
got a group of patients of the center
that have the same diagnosis and again
you're assuming that precision medicine
is going to be providing a diagnosis
there's amenable to the drug that's
being provided if not it does complicate
the situation but they're all even
though they have the same diagnosis
they're provided the same medicine so
when you start looking at what can
happen on the tough left-hand side
you've got the medicines are effective
and they're not toxic or they have or
they are toxic in this case on the
bottom left you've got the medicine is
not effective but it has toxicity the
bottom right hand side you have it's not
effective and it's not toxic so it's
totally useless to be able to take them
and then on the right hand side you have
the group that you want which is
efficacy and no toxicity and again let
me repeat that there over 160 for drugs
listed by the FDA okay they were
affected by genetics as drawings on
there on the package insert for the
medications so patient response
variability could very well be one of
the reasons why many medicines do not
work okay so the third factor has to do
with promoting polypharmacy this is a
lady looking at many many medicines all
at the same time and
was an article published in The Wall
Street Journal and back in 2011
indicating what were the hidden
influences that sway your medical
decisions for using more medicines and
it turns out their advertising was one
of them if you look carefully that
article indicated that for every one
thousand dollars in drug advertising it
translates into twenty four new
prescriptions by individual and that
two-thirds of the patients overestimated
the benefits of the treatments and as
many as ten times many of them believe
that it was ten times more effective
than it actually was
so advertising is a very strong
component of the push for more medicines
more drugs in medicine another reason
that I think is important that adds to
this entire complication is that when
you look at polypharmacy it embraces
many different multiple conditions so
patients that come to see physicians
have more than one clinical condition a
patient that has chronic pain could be
due because they have attention deficit
disorder or depression who have
arrhythmia may have hyperlipidemia and
hypertension also coronary artery
disease and maybe even diabetes combined
so these multiple conditions lead to
seeing multiple doctors which again many
many patients have and in the lease to
taking the wrong medicines at the wrong
time because you have multiple
prescriptions simultaneously so when you
add all of this together I think identic
ated four reasons why polypharmacy is a
pretty serious issue relative to whether
it can be helped in that so let's talk a
little bit about come a laboratory as
laboratory medicine discipline provide
some solution it starts with the idea
that I firmly believe is that the role
of the clinical laboratory has been
always to take bench side discoveries
through to the bedside and the
laboratory medicine acts as a catalyst
for this process so the question is can
we provide solutions to this potential
problem of polypharmacy
okay first thing I want to discuss is
the traditional therapeutic drug
monitoring approach that most clinical
laboratories have done for many years
it's a very valuable approach and for
medications that have a very narrow
therapeutic range in terms of
concentration and blood therapeutic drug
monitoring or what is referred to now as
therapeutic drug management or TDM
basically involves giving individuals
certain medications and then measuring
their concentrations and blood over time
to develop exactly how that person is
handling that medication typically that
measurement is done one time sometime
after the drug is taken and then
sometimes before the drug is
administered again and then adjustments
are made so it gives you information
about what the medication is basically
doing in blood and it does give you
relationships about the drug in blood
but does it tell you anything about the
drug transport a inside the body well
not really and when you start looking at
the drug receptors as TDM monitor and
healthy with the drug receptors actually
no because it doesn't provide that
information that's vitally necessary
well the question you might ask is can
pharmacokinetics link all three of these
concepts that come up with a package
that might be effective but drugs
selection and drug dosing we started my
interest in my my training program here
at the University of Louisville with a
review article that we publish in
clinical chemistry in 1997 and it was
titled pharmacogenetics a laboratory
tool for optimizing therapeutic
efficiency and this was published in 97
and then between that and 2010 the
national academy of clinical
biochemistry asked our group to begin a
group to start putting together
pharmacogenetics practice guidelines so
that they could be addressed from a
standpoint of good practice laboratory
medicine practice and JAMA published a
little article in 2006 indicating that
they caught wind that we were in fact
that the Academy was developing some of
these laboratory medicine practices so
this kind of started the process and
basically the whole premise behind this
concept was that you've got three legs
two
a triangle on the left hand side you've
got something we call pharmacokinetics
which is how the body culture is the
drug on the right hand side of the
triangle you have pharmacodynamics which
is how the drug affects the body and the
baseline of that triangle that links
both of these is something called
pharmacogenetics which is how genetics
impacts drug response okay and that was
the that was the embodiment of the
thinking behind trying to get clinical
laboratory information out there to help
physicians better manage patients so
this had to do with a whole concept
basically what what it involves is the
measurement of snips single nucleotide
polymorphisms okay to provide individual
genotypes specific for specific
medication and this all transcribed from
the idea that you know DNA will
transcribe RNA and RNA produces proteins
basically and those are the proteins
that are involved in three different
areas of protein head of drug handling
okay and those are metabolism proteins
transport proteins and receptor protein
and if you can put genetic information
together about those three into a drug
response profile okay you can get
basically something that can help in
terms of selecting of medication and
selecting the dosing so I've got listed
here a couple of those genes that are
involved in the area of metabolism
you've got spider clone p450 2d6
to see 19 I'll describe a little bit
about this a little bit later transport
proteins are SLO c19 basically and you
know that particular protein is a
protein that transports statins into the
liver and it's associated with my of
myopathy risks and then you've got the
OPR m1 basically gained its receptor
related to the MU opioid receptor for
hydromorphone morphine and other opioid
antagonist so a real question is can you
put all of this together as an effective
treatment if you look at its nautical
p450 just for one second the concept
here is that most drugs are lipophilic
when you take them and on the right-hand
side you'll see the by pathetic drugs
are excreted
our return to retain I'm sorry in that
retention can be to a buildup and what
you typically need to do is to bio
transform that drug into a hydrophilic
let's have a light and that hydrophilic
metabolites them to be managed by
excretion and that typically takes place
but we're known as cytochrome p450
proteins that exist in the liver and in
other parts of the body and this is
important because if you understand what
some of these are you can then
characterize individuals according to
this next slide into different
categories in terms of how well they
metabolize and this is only an example
of cytochrome p450 phenotypes you can
categorize them typically into either
extensive metabolizers which is really a
misnomer it's really more than normal
most prevalent metabolic situation for
patient or intermediate metabolizers
where maybe they have a copy of one of
the genes that makes this particular
protein or poor metabolizer where they
only have basically zero copies of the
gene and they're simply not producing
the the protein that's required from
metabolism this particular cytochrome
p450 also has a rapid metabolizers
status where you've got multiple copies
of the gene and that leads to very rapid
metabolism which in many cases requires
that you give higher doses in order to
compete with the metabolism and the
excretion so these little companies
little diagrams are very important to
try to identifying which category the
patient might fit so from a polypharmacy
perspective you might start to be
looking at well you know how many
medicines are there that are affected
just by 2d6
little mini ativ pathways along and
there are many many giving you a list
here I don't expect you to remember
these but they fall in the categories of
antidepressants antipsychotics SSRIs the
ritonavir uptake inhibitors beta
blockers opioids a number of opioids you
know and and many many other drugs so
this is something that's very ubiquitous
relative to drugs and are metabolized by
2d6 and that's only one of the many
sniffs analysis types that can be done
in laboratory medicine so when you begin
to look at all of this information
okay you then begin to think about well
how do you manage all of this
information if you're going to be
getting it and that's where something
but I I call diagnostic informatics
comes into play where on the left hand
side you've got molecular information
and on the right hand side you've got
informatics and how do you combine all
of those to maybe fine-tune personalized
medicine well there are several ways of
doing this there's an old way in a new
way a the new model which deals with the
issue of do we explain or we we predict
and on the left hand side is the older
model this was published by the review
and pharmacogenomics and year 2000 but
basically talks about the explanatory
role of pharmacokinetics this is a role
where you make a decision you use a drug
you use a standard of drug for that
particular condition and at those you
then have those adjustments that are
based on according to whether the drug
is working or whether you have adverse
events and then if you have better pre
refractoriness or adverse events you
then do a genotype to see if you can
explain what the problem might be for
this particular individual that's an
older way and I think that the modern
way of doing this thing is to try to
make a decision to use a specific
treatment and then do the genotyping and
let the genotyping basically draw and
guide the selection of the medicine and
the dosing mission and then if you have
further adjustments you can then do more
sophisticated analysis well the question
is did we test before or do we test
after I believe that the new guidelines
are going to indicate as we move along
in this discipline that we should test
before you take the medicines and if we
do that then what aspect of this is
really the important concept here that
one has to make a connection you need to
make a connection between the genotype
and the drug selection and the drug
dosage before you can make any
intelligent decisions about how to use
this try to predict what medicine to use
well I don't I don't want to do that
I'll give you an example of a drug turn
the warfarin is an anti coagulant that's
a very prevalent they used it's a being
used less
now because of other ones but but it's
one that has a very narrow therapeutic
reference range in blood and because of
that the bleeding you can get to
situations if you on the x-axis you'll
see here the INR measurement which is
the National normalization ratio which
needs to be kept as an antique way as a
coagulant indicator somewhere between
two and three that is the optimum way to
have that basically a normal human is
one but if you if it's much below that
your INR you have a high odds ratio for
stroke if it's much higher you can get
intracranial bleeding so it's a very
tight therapeutic range for this
medicine and it's very difficult to dose
and to select the right timing for the
dosing so this was a good example
because there were two issues about this
drug that made it a very good model to
begin and it had to do with the two
concepts that we've mentioned before
pharmacogenetics on the left and
pharmacodynamics on the right okay on
the left hand side relative to this
particular medicine oh you have 40% of
the population that are deficient in
cytochrome p 2 c 9 cytochrome p450 two
benign basically involves the metabolism
of this particular medication on the
right hand side we also understand that
it'll shift e percent of the population
and it have decreased the décor VCO arm
which is the receptor for this
particular drug okay as an enzyme
receptor so if you can combine both of
these pieces of information you might be
able to draw actionable information and
the reason you can do this is because if
you look at the summary of
pharmacogenetic linked functional
relationships for warfarin you'll see
that cyp2c9 sets the rate that is the
accumulation or the elimination of the
drug in other words the clearance and
that's associated with the need for
either decreased or increased
maintenance dosages b-corps on the other
hand the receptor is involved with the
effective concentration of the blood in
blood nest the warfarin pharmacodynamic
response it's associated with a specific
will refer maintenance dose that a
patient has to have so how is all of
this important and one of the most ways
to look at this that I
it's most critical is to look at what
happens during metabolism and
accumulation of the drug okay this is
basically what we call the dynamic
approach and in this figure I've got
three conditions where a patient has
three different genotypes for 2c9
the bottom one is to see nine star one
star one consider it to be a prevalent
normal and then you have star one star
two the middle bar the purple one and
then the green one is star one star
three and what the first thing that you
can see if you look at the s warfarin
concentration in blood on the left-hand
axis over time for specific dosing
you'll see two things number one is that
as you have a genetic variant of star
one star three you get a large
accumulation of the drug star one star
two is normal and you get to the
reference range very quickly basically
the red moviemakers but what's important
to hear are the little red arrows that
indicate when the drug reaches steady
state concentration in but and you'll
notice that for different genotypes okay
you reach steady state at a different
time so what we've been doing in the
past is trying to adjust the INR and the
dosing of the drug way before you reach
steady state which is something you
don't want to do in clinical
pharmacology understanding the genetics
will understand that it takes a certain
amount of time to get the steady state
and it is at that time when you can
begin to make adjustable so if you look
at this information one of the things
that was developed that this was one of
the one of the work that we did in our
University was trying to develop
algorithms that would put this
information together and there are other
algorithms available too and this shows
you an example on the blue on the on the
y-axis basically is the days after
prescribing warfarin with different
prescriptions times and the blue
indicates the actual concentration of
warfarin in blood for this one
particular patient and the little
squares that are gold indicates
basically the INR measurement at the
time and the dosing had to change
significantly and it kept changing and
it took almost
50 60 days to reach steady state and
this is because the information was not
known about the genetic predisposition
of this patient are they due Tuesday
9:00 or vcore but when we package the
information together and you put it in
an algorithm you're able to get a
solution that's basically based on
individualized dosing which means that
you can not only pre select the dosing
but you can please select the frequency
of the dosing in order to reach a stage
state condition within four or five days
preferably which is highly advantageous
so patients don't have to continue to go
back or worry about bleeding or stroke
in this situation so informatics and
really put this information together
I think bertinelli the next question is
well how do you go about doing this
and if you look carefully at the tape I
can take you back to the slide here
shows you this this shows basically the
typical implementation process that you
can find with just about any laboratory
that is doing for this kind of testing
most of the samples that have to be
drawn or either blood or the genotyping
or buccal swabs in some cases you can
phenotype based on saliva collections
some IRA Tories will do that we you know
we use very sophisticated chip array
technology now for the arrangement of
the snips and we're able to do panels
those laboratories that are
sophisticated if it's actually do panels
of snips and this is important because
that panel report then is submitted to
the clinician the minutes of the patient
and discuss with the patient because
you'd be surprised how many patients in
our experience are very very delighted
to know exactly what's going on relative
to their medicines it helps with
compliance and adherence to the
medication schedules and it helps the
doctor make a decision about it wishes
the best medicine to use so what kind of
information should be embodied in these
reports it's important that if you're
going to be looking okay you try to look
for information that is actionable and
when you have multi gene interpretations
this is just an example for example this
is a patient that was going to be
provided celexa
as a medication and he was this patient
he or she was a rapid ultra-rapid
metabolizer which increased the
metabolic clearance expected what
possible increased those requirements
okay but on the other hand the patient
was a poor metabolizer of SLC six a
fourth phenotype and that indicates an
increased risk of sub-therapeutic
response and side effects to an SSRI
which is medication thus there are other
medications that are suggested this
particular one was not and you should
consider switching to a non SSRI this is
what the report would indicate that is
not dependent on two c19 ultra rapid
metabolism excetera so you know it is
possible to provide valuable information
and a little deeper in this is seen on
the next slide
they were you looking at details of
multi-gene interpretation they should go
along with any of these reports for
example in the case of a Tuesday 19
rabid metabolizer you have increased
metabolic clearance and will remain that
okay with possible increase those
requirements and then you have basically
responses for you know an SL c 6a for
poor responder okay which means that
this medicine is those increases it's
not going to be effective then you have
two considerations for nun SR SSRI
selection of medicines awesome so in
many of these cases it's important to
have the interpretive result very clear
upfront and then you know the rationale
is to why so the doctors can make
intelligent decisions so let's look at a
little something this was a study that
was done in our laboratory and what we
did is in the process of testing
patients we were able to show you know
that there's a likely but a high
likelihood of being able to provide
actual guidance there was guidance in 73
percent of the patients that we test
that this is a small sample we took a
750 patients that were managed by 27
different doctors with a different range
of specialties and on the front and the
bottom axis you see the number of drug
gene interactions okay or moderate major
were contraindicated severity per
patient and on the left hand side the
number
so out of 705 only 55 had no indications
minor indications 39 and then the rest
had as many as two three four five and
seven indications based on genetic
difficulties patient might run into him
when you look at the data a little bit
closer okay you can see that on the 27
participating physicians and the
different specialties in listening their
general practitioner psychiatry
cardiology pain management in
gerontology there were 700 of my
patients Toni medications that were
being taken were over 8,000 okay we're
at least 3,000 had drug drug
interactions that included the minor
interaction of drugs and there was total
meds with genetic implications were
almost 3,000 evenly distributed
practically between psychotropics
cardiovascular pain management when you
look carefully at this particular group
only the average number of minutes per
patient was 12 and the average number of
minutes per patient with a genetic
implication where action could have been
taken listen for so you know almost a
quarter to a third and this implication
now I indicated to you that I was going
to come back to this particular a series
of studies that we did here this is a
availability pot well it was a returning
population of over 30,000 individuals
and the enemy x axes are the number of
patients the number of medications that
need to pay each group of patients were
taking and the y-axis the number of
patients take a little particular group
and have indicated that there were 92
percent it will take him through more
but take a look at the spectrum here I
mean you have a very large group taken
seven 911 medicines you have individuals
that were taken upwards of 20 and some
were taken in the vicinity of higher
than 30 but this has rather important
health and financial advantages in terms
of being able to correct this
polypharmacy problem as an example in
this particular group but if you look at
the opiates analgesics of 46 percent of
patients that were prescribed
pro drug okay
for pain management well not benefit
benefit out of the 30,000 11,000 and
were prescribed opiates 5,000 subjects
that had conflicts okay and this
translated into over a hundred dollars
average cost waste per subject with an
annual expense rate of at least five
hundred you know half a million dollars
and this is only the beginning because
when you started to look at all the
other complications in terms of opioids
and serotonin reuptake inhibitors in
cardiovascular you know you notice that
86% of the SSRIs at one or more genetic
conflict and possibly half of those that
was single gene conflict and the other
half of those had both the cyp and
basically an SL transport receptor
conflict - and then in the case of
cardiovascular medications anywhere from
chlorophyll Peter grill warfarin beta
blockers or statin and statins they all
had large percentages of the medications
that had gene conflicts so it's a
serious problem that has you know
potential complications I don't only for
patient but the other complication that
it has is that it's very costly it can
be very very cost savings we did this
study basically that looked at the cost
savings that could be substantial
because again looking the algorithm we
use we experienced something we took the
same data and then we extrapolated the
advantages of properly using
antidepressants will be it non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories were for an epidural
and polypharmacy related to some others
and the actual cost reduction are
estimated per year basis for over two
point two million saving per thousand
patients so when you look at the
cost-effectiveness of this you seriously
have to consider that some of these
pharmacy benefit programs you know have
thousands of patients and if they could
save as much money every year using
pharmacogenetic information might be a
very good way to start the process of
guiding a selection of medicines and the
dosing so when you begin to look at the
health
effectiveness it's important to
recognize that the first drug selected
needs to be the right drug medication
failures who got either inefficiency or
in tolerability or both leads to a
continuum of risk and to the rise in
part polypharmacy which already know us
is the condition so you begin with the
wrong drug you get treatment resistance
at servation goes on to hospitalization
polypharmacy and then that cost that are
associated with that so it seems to me
like the data strongly suggest that
pharmacogenetics as a good concept can
actually identify patients with high
risks of failure and provide actionable
guidance for alternative medication
management so along those lines you know
you want to consider if you are going to
be dealing with something like
polypharmacy that deals with many
conditions it's important to know
whether you've got you know it
appropriate information that's linked to
many different conditions and we have
you know genetic patterns and panels are
available right now for pharmacogenomics
dealing with oncology cardiovascular
panels psychiatry very important
respiratory and pain management and I
believe that some infectious diseases
and immunology will soon be coming as we
discover more snips that are
specifically related to those diseases
and the treatments so basically you know
when you stop and think about how is it
best to generate this information well
my thinking at the moment is that it's
probably wise if we had a systems
approach where you had virtual
pharmacotherapy clinics they could be
approached vertically platforms okay
that use diagnostic informatics models
for linking fragmented practices so the
doctors could link up online with your
specific genetic information to be able
to give you specific guidance as to what
medicine they should use I knew
specifically as a person and the dosing
and be able to do that at the time of
point of care that this is a concept
that I think really needs to be stepped
up a little bit and it's going to make a
huge difference I believe and that's my
personal opinion about how to roll this
they said let me go back to indicate
that if you want more information on how
you might be able to reduce polypharmacy
laboratory medicine there's a recent
clinic's review articles that were
published by myself and my colleague dr.
Reynolds and it has a variety of 25
different authors that are contributing
chapters and it's a good review that can
might give you some information about
not only the fundamentals of
pharmacogenomics and I think you can go
online and then figure out how to get
these these are available online I
believe do clinics review particles
alright so let me just take a moment
here to review what we've been able to
do so far and the things that we
discussed firstly we discussed of
precision and personalized medicine what
the different definitions for those two
are and how they basically complement
each other by linking both diagnostic
and therapeutic okay we then looked at
polypharmacy and what the problem was in
terms of too many medicines are being
used many of them are not functional and
actually lead the hospitalization and
numerus clausus we also then looked at
pharmacogenomics as a potential solution
where clinical laboratories can provide
very detailed information it provides
the guidance for intelligent prescribing
a selection of medication I think
there's a there's a future for
laboratory medicines that have a very
huge end and then how to implement the
process the concept of these diagnostic
informatics making molecular information
combining it's officiated informatics
algorithms to then provide guidance
specific guidance on a specific patient
taking you back understanding that
you've got to have precision medicine
relative to the diagnosis and then
personalized medicine relative to the
actual selection of the medications so
with that I'd like to thank you for your
attendance the whole idea has to do with
transitioning molecular technologies to
healthcare again I believe that the
clinical labs are a tremendous catalyst
for taking molecule
making happy doctors by fine-tuning
personalized medicine thank you very
much for your attention and possibly we
can take some questions if you have some
time thank you doctor Valdes for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
in the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started with our first
question
dr. Valdes you mentioned several
situations that led up to multiple use
of meds which of those you feel the
clinical laboratory could have the
highest impact in terms of helping to
reduce multiple drug use oh yeah okay
well that's not so they're very targeted
question and I think it's a very
appropriate one because first thing we
need to understand it there are certain
things that the laboratory is not going
to be able to do for example it isn't
going to control the amount of
advertising that's taking place now in
terms of trying to get more medications
into patients and into the market so
there's little control there the other
little control that we have are the
multiple conditions basically the
patients might have and they do have
these and it's very legitimate to
provide different medicines so the
laboratory certainly cannot control that
but where can't control okay is to
really impact on number one the
selection of the medication that may be
appropriate for the individual and the
right dosing for that medication in
order to avoid medication Cascades so
that this particular guidance is related
to proper selection of medicine and
increasing the effectiveness of medicine
as we work through this so I think those
are the two main areas that the
laboratory can have the most significant
impact
I hope that answered your question
I thought the target
absolutely thank you so much
the next question asks the issue of
paying for the pharmacogenetics tests
always comes up are these tests covered
by insurance at this time well okay well
that's that is interesting and this
varies frankly I mean I've been I've
been in the clinical laboratory business
for quite a while and I know that
insurance coverage is always an issue
and sometimes it does fluctuate I can
tell you that right now
CMS who Medicare does cover some of the
pharmacogenetic tests it covers three or
four of the tests sometimes as high as
five and is limited to some of those
okay private payers are mixed what I
found is that some will pay for some of
the tests and others will not so it's
important for the patient to find out
whether these are covered or not you
know by the medication so I do believe
however that the cost of the tests are
decreasing very rapidly from year to
year in terms of being able to provide
this diagnostic information and because
of that I believe that the two things
that are happening is that the costs are
being reduced in order to provide it and
secondly there is more and more
recognition that in fact this is useful
information so my guess is that CMS will
begin to cover more of the tests and
private payers will follow and cover
more and we also recognize that in the
future CMS is going to be basing their
their cost basis and the early payments
based on the private sector so I have a
feeling that there's going to be unity
between the two and that more of these
tests will be covered so like yeah I see
a good future for coverage for these
tests and again the expense is low
enough now in some of these situations
where if patients might be able to cover
it themselves and their you know payment
programs thanks so much for those
insights sounds like good news the next
question asks do you see the value in
genotyping all individual individuals in
order to have
information available at times of
prescription and is feasible cost wide
cost wise well yes yes I actually well
it depends really I think that you know
the first thing we have to get over is
this fear that genotyping individuals is
bad and this is one of the things that
you know has had a drawback in the use
of this information because many people
don't want their genetic information
available but what is important to
understand is that the type of
information that is obtained by a
laboratory for purposes of
pharmacogenetic testing it's not it's
not basically indicating anything about
a disease process or predicting your
future health etc it's really focused on
a very targeted use and that really does
target the information and because of
that I think that more and more people
are realizing that yeah I think it is
important for us to start getting this
information into our medical record so
you know the idea that we can genotype
individuals early on in life is probably
people have proposed this at birth it
may be a little bit of a stretch at this
point but certainly when you begin to
start getting different illnesses and
you begin to start aging and requiring
more and more attention medically that
might be a good time to actually start
thinking about doing genotyping that
will put your medicine record on record
so the doctors can use it so yeah I
think it does make sense to develop
platforms they're going to be able to
take this information and use it thank
you so much for your answer appears we
have time for one last question today
this question asks would you recommend
testing for panels of pharmacogenomics
tests as opposed to selecting specific
tests based on anticipated medications
yes I really do and the reason for that
as you as I indicated earlier one needs
to understand that because the
combination of genotypes sets a balance
for how much medication may be
prescribed or which one might be
effective but knowing one or two
genotypes only is not going to be
sufficient
the most sophisticated algorithms use
panels I have found basically a work
that's done by my colleagues in my
laboratory that usually around twelve to
fourteen back tests is what's optimally
necessary it links up with databases
about drug drug interactions which can
also be brought into the algorithms and
those are the main ones around twelve to
fourteen that have the best description
in the literature in terms of their
effects so I certainly recommend that
panels be considered I think that
limiting it to just a few because you're
taking one medicine or anticipating
taking two oh really is not optimum in
terms of doing the complete balance of
how one of these genotypes might
counterbalance the effects of the other
in terms of the drug selection I think I
alluded to a few examples and and some
of those examples in the literature can
be seen by some of the references and a
little textbook that I recommend it so
yes I do recommend panels over a
specific genotypes yeah thank you
excellent well thank you dr. Valdes for
your presentation today and I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I'd like to let everyone
know that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
July of 2018 you will receive an email
from lab birds letting you know when
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you here again soon at laberd's
thank you and have a great day goodbye